somehow in the last presidential
election joe biden got 12 million more
votes than barack obama who was the
second coming of christ as you remember
12 million more votes how'd that happen
exactly well today at the latest january
6th hearing liz cheney of wyoming
explained shut up
say a word about mail in balloting and
you're immoral watch
the president understood even before the
election that many more biden voters had
voted by mail because president trump
ignored the advice of his campaign
experts and told his supporters only to
vote in person
former president trump's plan to
overturn the election relied on a
sustained effort to deceive millions of
americans but he betrayed the trust of
the american people
he ignored the will of the voters
he lied to his supporters and the
country
and as a result of his loss
decided to wage an attack on our
democracy
an attack on american people by trying
to rob you of your voice in our
democracy
trump is bad
thanks mom new message from the
democratic party but what's the answer
reassure us that the last election was
on the level
no this show trial is not reassuring
anyone this whole effort of course isn't
is an attempt to punish anybody who
challenges the reigning orthodoxy ryan
kelly learned that the hard way ryan
kelly is running for governor in
michigan at least one poll had him
leading the republicans running for
governor of michigan he was just
arrested last week because he was at the
capitol protest on january 6.
we've been wanting to talk to him
tonight we can miss kelly thanks so much
for coming on um so just to get the
factual stuff right out did you commit a
crime on january 6th
there was no crime committed tucker no
never entered the capitol building
exercising my first amendment
those of us that have questions about
the
2020 election results they want to
intimidate us and they want to threaten
us not just me my family but my
supporters as well all of us that love
america
so the government doesn't typically
arrest leading candidates in
gubernatorial races unless they have you
on video accepting cash and putting in
your freezer or something which is not
the case here were you surprised that
federal agents showed up at your home
it was definitely a surprise i think
that it's a narrative that the democrats
have been pushing because of their
failed policies in regard to energy and
regard to all of the things that matter
to americans and we see this continued
left-wing agenda being pushed and this
january 6 committee i think a lot of
americans see right through this tucker
they understand what the democrats are
up to and it's not a big deal to them
they want to know what the what the
government is going to do to actually do
the things that are affecting their
day-to-day life to bring solutions to
our state and to our country and so we
see just this continuation of the left
pushing further left and common sense
reasonable people like myself stepping
up to make sure we save our state and
our country and bring relief to american
families but i mean arresting people
seems i mean that's a brand new frontier
in american politics from what i can
tell you aren't doing anything different
in fact you're doing things that seem
much less criminal than say ray epps who
has not been arrested and there are many
others who are on video standing where
you're standing or not arrested
do you think there was a political
motive here in arresting you as a
candidate
absolutely a political motive just 12
hours before i was arrested joe biden
was on jimmy kimmel saying that he's
going to arrest his political opponents
there's no coincidence in the timing of
this tucker it's right in alignment with
all of this political theater that the
democrats are pushing with their j6
committee and there's there's no
coincidence here and you know like you
said some of the polls are showing that
i'm winning the support has been
tremendous we see new polls now where my
lead has grown substantially and i take
that as a sign of you know gratitude to
my supporters for all of the things that
they've stepped up and helped with and
just a reason for me to work twice as
hard get my message out there so i can
serve the great people of michigan as
our next governor
so you're running
bold gods i'm running yes sir amen ryan
kelly thank you we're moving forward we
intend to win on january and uh and
hope we still there
yep i appreciate it thank you we intend
to win on the
on 2nd of august and again in november
making gretchen whitmer a one-term
governor we'll be watching thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight